[Applause]
golden knights back in the fortress
tonight after a successful two-game road
trip that's right vegas won both of
those road games and they're now looking
to keep the momentum going tonight here
on home ice 8 sports reporter kevin
martin is live outside toshiba plaza
with a preview of tonight's matchup hey
kevin
well hey christian heading into that two
game road trip the golden knights were
desperate for a win as they were riding
a four game losing streak and that's
exactly what they got picking up four
huge points improving at three and four
on the season and tonight they look to
carry that momentum here against the
anaheim ducks and earlier today head
coach pete deboer said it was the
attention to detail they got them those
back back-to-back wins and wants to see
them continue that here tonight
well the colorado game for sure you know
i thought we did a really good job on on
a on a very good team
and some obviously world class players
and got rewarded for that i thought in
the dallas game
probably from
the seven minute mark of the second
seven minutes left in the second period
through the third i thought we did